how's it goin everybody it's Warren and
Avengers endgame was an amazing movie it
was truly a movie for the fans and it
also did justice to the story arcs that
the MCU has been building over the past
11 years this movie is packed with
Easter eggs and callbacks and references
to the comics in previous MCU films and
it's just so rewarding to watch so let's
break down the whole entire movie and go
over the details that you might have
missed but of course I first must issue
a spoiler alert if you have not seen
Avengers in-game I will be going over
the entire movie in this video so if you
don't want essentially the whole movie
spoiled you should click away and also
if you're new to my channel be sure to
hit that subscribe button I'm giving
away a life-sized Infinity Gauntlet
right now and a glow-in-the-dark fan
oohs painting by globe I bow I'll get
into more the giveaway stuff at the end
of the video so the first scene of
avengers endgame opens up on Hawkeye
teaching his daughter how to shoot a bow
and arrow he's at his home on the
countryside and we can see his wife and
two sons in the background as well the
first line of the movie that Clint says
you know where you are going
now let's worry about how you get there
this is actually a reference to the
beginning of the MCU Marvel had been
planning all of these MCU interconnected
films a long time before Iron Man 1 so
they saw where they were going they just
needed to focus on how to get there and
they started with Iron Man there's a few
Easter eggs and callbacks in this scene
if you notice Clint calls his daughter
Hawkeye and this is the first time we
actually hear Hawkeye in the MCU the
closest that we've ever gotten is in the
first Avengers film when dr. Erik Selvig
calls him the hawk and you can also
notice that he still has his ankle
bracelet on therefore he is still on
house arrest after the events of civil
war both Hawkeye and ant-man took plea
deals with the government so they could
go be with their families and also
Hawkeye's daughter is played by Ava
Russo the daughter of Jove Russo who
directed the film along with his brother
Anthony Russo but sadly her and the rest
of Clint's family turned to dust leaving
him all alone and leading him to
becoming Ronin we then cut to the
benatar which Tony and nebula are
stranded on and we hear dear mr. fantasy
plane in the background this is no doubt
quills music and it either comes from
one of his awesome mixes or his Zune we
see Tony and
bula plain paper football to pass the
time and try to keep their hopes up and
it goes along with the music that says
take us out of this gloom
we then see Tony recording his message
to pepper saying that they've done
everything they can but the ship is
stranded he's ran out of food and water
and tomorrow morning he will run out of
oxygen there are actually a ton of
Easter eggs callbacks and references in
this one scene alone
for starters we hear Tony Stark's say
don't post this on social media this is
a callback to the first Ironman when
he's in the convoy and he says don't
post this on MySpace
we then hear him say that he's been
stranded in space for 22 days well
Avengers endgame is the twenty second
film of the MCU we then hear Tony call
nebula a blue meanie which is from the
Beatles Yellow Submarine where the
Beatles actually travel through time
there's also a reference to the Beatles
and Avengers infinity war where Tony
says the Avengers broke up and Bruce
Banner asks like a band like the Beatles
ah
foreshadowing when we see Tony and
nebula working on the ship to try to fix
it he's wearing a black tank top just
like he's wearing in the first Iron Man
film when he's making the mock one at
the end of his message he tells pepper
I'll think of you it's always you this
is a callback to Iron Man 2 when he
makes pepper the CEO of Stark Industries
he says it's you it's always been you
Tony passes out and is about to die but
the nebula picks him up and puts him in
the chair fully expecting him to be dead
any time now but then Tony sees a super
bright light and it is of course the one
and only Captain Marvel coming to save
Tony
Captain Marvel takes the Benatar back to
earth and back to the Avengers
headquarters where the rest of the
Avengers and pepper are waiting for them
now it's interesting that they didn't
show in Avengers in game Captain Marvel
meeting the Avengers they counted on you
seeing the post-credits scene from
Avengers infinity war and the
post-credits scene from Captain Marvel
to know what happened and what happened
was the Avengers got their hands on Nick
Fury's pager we don't know how but they
did Captain Marvel traced the signal and
showed up asking where's fury from here
no doubt she explained who she was and
we can probably assume that Pepper
showed up to the Avengers headquarters
and told the rest of the Avengers that
Tony went into space and from here
Captain Marvel tracked them down most
likely with the help of Rockets since
that is his ship when they get home
nebula is helping Tony off the ship and
Captain of course runs to his aid he
tells captain I couldn't stop him and
Captain says we couldn't eat
and then Tony says I lost the kid of
course referring to Peter Parker Tony
actually doesn't know if pepper is alive
at this point or if she's fallen victim
to the snap he's about to ask captain if
she's alive or not but then she runs up
to him and embraces him we cut to a
scene inside the Avengers headquarters
and we can see that Tony still has a lot
of resentment from what happened in
civil war he still doesn't forgive Steve
this is the first time that we really
see the damage that was caused by Civil
War
Tony references back to age of Ultron
many times in the scene he think calls
everybody out saying that he wanted a
suit of armor around the world like he
said in age of Ultron implying that if
he had those suits of armor around the
world this wouldn't have happened
but then he talks about how Captain
didn't agree with him and how Tony said
that they'd lose and then Captain said
they lose together Tony then refers back
to the vision that he had an age of
Ultron saying that he saw this coming in
this scene we can tell just how afraid
of Thanos Tony Stark really is
understandably of course he just got the
crap kicked out of them by Thanos and
Thanos just eliminated half of the
universe but he gives Steve his arc
reactor and says that if you find
thinness you wear this and you hide
basically telling him that you cannot
defeat Thanos we can see that Tony still
has a lot of resentment left for Steve
after the events of civil war ultimately
Tony ends up collapsing due to lack of
strength and ends up on bed rest with
nebula Bakshi figures out where Thanos
is with the help of rocket nebula says
that Fay knows has gone and retired at
the garden which is a biblical reference
such as the Garden of Eden this is
because after thinness collects all of
the Infinity stones and has control over
the entire universe he deems himself a
god and this is straight from the comics
as well also when the Avengers get to
the garden we can see Fanus scarecrow
armor which is directly from the
Infinity Gauntlet comics so the Avengers
get in the Benatar and head into space
to go kill thanos in the scene we can
see that Captain America is actually
wearing his uniform from the Winter
Soldier the first scene of Thanos on the
garden is of him brushing his hands
against some flowers this is taken
directly from the movie Gladiator where
Maximus brushes his hands against some
weeds this is actually for shadows
Thanos is death much like Maximus and
gladiator we find out that Thanos used
the Infinity stones to destroy the
Infinity stones and then Thor finally
goes for the head and kills Thanos they
is now dead but the stones are destroyed
and the Avengers lose all hope we then
cut to five years later without the
stones the Avengers did not know how to
reverse the snap so they did their best
to try and move on with their lives
Steve Rogers hosts a support group for
those who have lost people to the snap
in the support group we see two very
important people
one is director of Avengers infinity war
and Avengers endgame Joe Russo Joe Russo
is who we hear talking in the support
group saying that he went on a date for
the first time in a very long time in
this scene he also marks the first
openly gay character in the MCU but also
in the support group is the one and only
jim Starlin jim Starlin created Thanos
and he wrote the Infinity Gauntlet comic
saga we then cut to a scene with Natasha
talking to some of the other heroes who
are all looking after the world and
other parts of the universe now next to
Natasha on the floor we can see ballet
shoes which is a reference to her past
as a child and her past that we learned
in age of Ultron one very interesting
and possibly very important part of this
scene is when a Koi he tells Natasha
that there was an underwater earthquake
off of the coast of Africa this is most
likely an Easter Egg for Namor the
Submariner Namor has been teased by
Marvel Studios President Kevin Feige for
a very long time now and this actually
isn't the first Easter Egg for Namor in
the MCU Akoya says it's an underground
earthquake we handle it by not handling
it this could simply be just an
underground earthquake but to me it does
look like she knows that it could be
Namor and the people of Atlantis well
Conda and Atlantis and the comics are
constantly at war with one another so
she may know that this earthquake is
caused by name wherein the Atlanteans
and she knows just to leave it alone
when everybody leaves we see Captain
Marvel look at Rhodey in a very
interesting way and she says be careful
well in the comics Rhodey and Captain
Marvel are actually kind of a thing
meaning they're romantically involved
with one another which actually makes a
lot of sense considering that they have
a lot in common including serving in the
military the scene ends with Natasha
asking Rhodey if she can track down
where Clint is going next then Captain
America comes in and says that I've been
telling people to move on and some
people move on but not us the heroes
clearly cannot move on after they failed
to stop Thanos and failed to save the
universe meanwhile in California the
whole entire universe is saved by a rat
that's right a rat stepped on a switch
that brought ant-man back to the current
time and the Russo brothers have
actually confirmed this they said that
in all of the 14 million different
scenarios the rat did not step on the
switch all but one time so it seems like
the Avengers owe everything to Master
Splinter the storage number that the van
is being kept in is six one six which is
a reference to the main comic universe
earth-616 and the security guard is kim
ji-young Kim was on community which as I
showed that the Risa brothers also
directed as well so a little community
Easter Egg there the security guard is
also reading the terminal Beach which is
actually a post apocalyptic book which
is pretty much the world that the
Avengers live in right now a
post-apocalyptic or a post snap reality
so ant-man gets out of the quantum realm
and as we know he only spent five hours
inside of the quantum realm but five
years went by in reality he has no idea
what happened but eventually realizes
that millions of people are dead and
missing all he can think about is if his
daughter is alive or not he goes to a
memorial that has all of the people who
died to the snap listed on it he's
looking for his daughter but actually
finds out that his name is on it this
makes perfect sense because he was
trapped inside of the quantum realm for
five years so everybody thought that he
was dead he goes to Cassies house and he
finds her there five years older she's
obviously in shock because she thought
he was dead but then ant-man travels
across the country to upstate New York
with the van that has the quantum tunnel
in it and he brings hope in the form of
possible time travel Steve Natasha and
Scott go see Tony to talk about time
travel and we find out that Tony now has
a daughter Morgan this is from Avengers
infinity war where Tony tells Pepper
that he had a dream where they had a
child named Morgan named after peppers
eccentric uncle Morgan now in the comics
there is a Morgan Stark but it is not
Tony and peppers daughter it's actually
Tony's cousin who is very jealous of
Tony in the scene we also see his
daughter wearing the helmet to the
rescue armor that Pepper will wear later
on in the ending of the movie this also
has a double reference to it as it
refers back to Iron Man 2 with the
little boy wearing the Iron Man helmet
which was actually Peter Parker when
Steve Natasha and Scott show up we can
see Natasha is wearing an arrow necklace
which is a reference to Hawkeye Scott
explains the quantum realm and time
travel to Tony but Tony quickly
dismisses it he says that it's too risky
and he
risk his family but when he's washing
the dishes later on that night he sees a
picture of Peter and of course decides
to give time-travel ago and figures it
out while he's tucking his daughter into
bed she says I love you 3000 which is
actually a reference to the ironman 3000
conversion table oddly enough but of
course would actually bring people to
tears at the end of the movie Tony tells
pepper I figured it out I figured out
time travel but it's risky and he's
thinking about just forgetting about it
and heading to bed to go to sleep and
then pepper drops some deep stuff on us
by saying but would you actually rest
this is a reference to Iron Man 3 where
Tony would try to sleep but he couldn't
because he would have nightmares we then
get introduced to Professor Hulk for the
very first time Professor Hulk is the
perfect combination of Bruce Banner and
the Hulk you have the brains of Bruce
Banner but the body of the Hulk
professor Hulk and the rest of the
Avengers will attempt time-travel but
not be too successful at it Tony
eventually heads back to the Avengers
headquarters he gives Captain America
his shield back and when he gives it to
him the theme from the First Avenger
plays Tony tell Steve that he has
forgiven him and wants to put everything
behind him and Steve agrees then Tony
says that they need to get all of the
team back together and Steve says that
they're working on it professor Hulk and
rocket then go visit new Asgard now new
Asgard is in Norway in a city called
tongs burg in the original Thor movie we
learned that this is where Odin fought
off the frost giants this is also the
place where Odin had the tesseract in
Captain America the First Avenger and
it's also a callback to Thor Ragnarok
where Odin was on earth in Norway and he
said Asgard could be here we see that
rocket is in his original guardians of
the galaxy outfit from the comics and
when they get to new Asgard we find out
that Valkyrie is in fact alive and when
rocket and Professor Hulk get to Thor's
cabin we find out that Korg and meek
also survived the snap thank goodness we
find out that Thor isn't exactly in the
best of shape mentally and definitely
physically Thor is rockin the dad bod
and it becomes very clear that the guilt
of Thor not going for the head
originally and not stopping Thanos from
killing half of the universe has
definitely taken its toll on Thor he
stays drunk all the time so he doesn't
have to deal with the pain of his
failure and when Professor Hulk says
Thanos he has a meltdown but eventually
rocket convinces Thor to go with them
because they
a chance to undo the snap and there's
beer on the ship but there's also a
quick little fortnight easter-egg in the
scene the Russo brothers are very big
Fortnite fans in fact in an infinity war
Q&A with Collider Anthony Russo wore a
fortnight's shirt we are then introduced
to Ronan
Clint's other persona after his family
died this happens in the comics as well
Hawkeye takes on the Ronin persona after
Civil War we see him kill Akihiko who
was the Yakuza boss and a member of the
Shogun reapers a science clan who fought
against shield in the comics natasha
finds Clint and convinces him to come
back because they have hoped now there's
a chance that they can undo the snap and
bring back Clint's family
The Avengers all get back together at
the Avengers headquarters and they
decide to test time-travel it's
successful and the Hulk explains how
time travel works he explains that if
you go back in time and alter events of
the past it does not change your future
instead it creates an alternate timeline
so the Avengers come up with their plan
to go into the past and collect all of
the Infinity stones Scott calls this
plan a time heist which is a direct
reference to a Doctor Who episode which
is a fan favorite we also catched the
Hulk eating his own ice cream which was
mentioned in Avengers infinity war while
they're coming up with their time heist
plan and Thor hasn't exactly gotten his
act together and in fact looks like the
dude from Big Lebowski which is actually
referenced in this movie while Thor is
explaining about the ether and where it
is we see a photo of Jane Foster which
is the same photo used in the first
Avengers film The Avengers only have
enough Pym particles to make one jump to
the past and one jump back so they split
up into teams going to different points
in time
Steve Tony Scott and Professor Hulk will
go back to 2012 there they will try to
get the time stone the mind stone and
the space stone rocket and Thor will go
back to Asgard right during the events
of Thor the dark world and there they
will try to get the ether nebula Clint
Rhodey and Natasha will go back to 2014
Clinton Natasha will go to Vermeer and
Rhodey and nebula will go to Morag this
team is in charge of getting the Power
Stone and the soul stone as I said Thor
and rocket go back to the events of Thor
the dark world and we see Loki trapped
inside of a cell Thor is still not in
the best shape mentally and freaks out
and starts to have a panic attack
rocket tries to pull him back together
but he can't leaving rocket to go get
the ether by himself Thor then runs into
his mother who immediately knows that he
is not from the current time
he breaks down and she tells him that he
needs to be who he is and not who he is
supposed to be and also tells him to eat
a salad but this snaps him back in the
shape and rocket manages to get the
ether but before they head back of
course Thor has to grab mule near he's
able to grab it which means he is still
worthy enough to wield it and this also
restores his confidence as well back in
2012 we have a whole bunch of nostalgia
reliving the events of the first
Avengers film and here we get to see a
lot of behind the scenes events that we
didn't see in the Avengers film we see
Loki turn into Captain America like he
does and Thor the dark world and then
Thor slap something over his face to
make him shut up and then shield or
Hydra comes in and they take the scepter
on their way down and the elevator
Captain America gets in the elevator and
it seems like we're going to relive this
scene from the Winter Soldier instead
Steve whispers into sitwell's ear hail
Hydra this is a reference to the comics
where Steve is actually brainwashed into
thinking that he is a Hydra agent in the
elevator we also hear some Hydra agents
name-drop dr. lists who is Baron von
strucker's chief scientist who studied
the scepter and age of Ultron
we then see Captain America fight
Captain America the 2012 Captain America
thinks that the future Captain America
is actually Loki in disguise trying to
steal the scepter we hear 2012 captain
say I can do this all day which is
basically Captain America's catchphrase
at this point in this scene we actually
see how much captain has grown over the
years from the captain that would say
language an age of Ultron to the captain
now who checks out his own but meanwhile
the ancient one explains the Bruce
Banner that change in the past can
create alternate timelines alternate
timelines actually happened quite
frequently in the comics but Bruce
promises to return each Infinity stone
to the point in time where they took
them that way no alternative timelines
would be created however they do create
alternate timelines in 2012 Loki manages
to get the tesseract and escape opening
his story up to a whole bunch of
different possibilities in the future of
the MCU and 2014 nebula is now killed
and 2014 Gamora is now in 2023 so they
have definitely created alternate
timelines that I'm sure we'll see play
out in the MCU at some point the ancient
one was not going to give the time stone
to Bruce until Bruce says that Doctor
Strange willingly gave up the time stone
to Thanos she explains that he is
supposed to be the best
master of the mystic arts out of all of
the ones before so she agrees that he
must have known what he was doing when
he gave away the time stone and of
course as we know he did he looked into
the future and saw 14 million six
hundred and five different scenarios in
which they only won one but part of that
winning scenario was giving away the
time stone in New York they managed to
get the time stone and the mine stone
however they don't managed to get the
space stone because Loki escapes with it
so they go back in time to the 1940s to
camp Lehi this is the camp where Steve
was first trained but would later on be
destroyed in the Winter Soldier but of
course before the scene starts we have
what is expected to be the very last
cameo from standin manly he drives by
yelling at the government with a bumper
sticker on his car that says nuff said
which is a catchphrase that he would use
in the Marvel Comics in this scene we
see dr. Hank Pym of the past working on
the original ant-man helmet captain is
in disguise and on his nametag we can
see that it says Rosco this is an Easter
Egg to Roscoe Simmons who would
eventually take the mantle in the comics
of Captain America when he goes Nomad
toni eventually runs into his father
Howard Stark Tony pulls out an MIT badge
which is a reference to Captain America
Civil War when he spoke at MIT this is
where he got that badge Civil War of
course is also where Tony and Steve got
divided and now they're working together
again Howard Stark is looking for dr.
Zola who has red skulls chief scientists
who joined shield but was secretly
working for Hydra going back into the
past and talking to his father is
actually a great moment for Tony
now that Tony is a father himself the
man who he thought was really hard on
him he realizes was just trying to do
his best and Tony finally get some
closure with his father we also see
Jarvis who would eventually go on to
become the voice of Tony's AI Jarvis is
also an easter egg to the show agent
Carter who of course Steve manages to
see while he's back on the base we can
go to Morag with Rhodey and nebula and
we get to see star-lord from a different
perspective it managed to track down the
Power Stone but right before they get it
ready says you can't just enter the
Temple of the Power Stone it's
booby-trapped and this of course is a
reference to Indiana Jones the Raiders
of the Lost Ark then on vermeer we
basically have the same scene that we
saw in Avengers infinity war with fan
oohs and gomorrah only this time is with
Natasha and Clint they realized that one
of them has to be sacrificed and
obviously they both want to sacrifice
themselves Natasha says that it
has to be heard because this is what her
life has been building up to and besides
she owes Clint for saving her life and
giving her a family this is a reference
to the first Avengers film where Natasha
tells Loki that Clint basically saved
her life instead of killing her the two
of them fight both trying to kill
themselves until eventually Natasha is
the one that sacrifices herself and
client gets the soul stone
everybody manages to get back except of
course for nebula who ends up getting
trapped by the past Thanos Thanos learns
of the future of vengers plan and sins
the past nebula back to the future but
the Avengers successfully collected all
of the Infinity stones and Thor wants to
be the one to perform the snap because
it would make up for him not going for
tanis's head and not saving everybody
trying to undo his wrong he says that he
is the strongest Avenger which is a
reference to Thor Ragnarok when he tried
to access the Quinn jet but at the end
of the day it is Professor Hulk that
wields the Infinity Gauntlet
saying that he was basically made for
this because it's mostly gamma radiation
which is really what the Hulk is right
before the snap we see Tony use his
energy shield which we see Captain
America used in the comics professor
hoax excessively undoes the snap but
immediately after nebula brings the 2014
Thanos and his army into the future and
he immediately launches an attack on the
building completely destroying it we
have a scene where Hulk is holding up
the building in order to save Rhodey and
rocket this comes directly from the
Secret Wars comic we then get to see a
new Thanos Thanos from the past who is
much more like the Fantas from the
comics the brutal mad Titan who just
wants to kill everybody we didn't get a
face-off with the original three
Avengers Iron Man Thor and Captain
America against Thanos Thor wields mule
near and Stormbreaker and the three of
them launch an attack against Thanos
Thanos still manages to overpower them
and at one point phantoms is about to
drive Stormbreaker into Thor's chest
this is a reverse scene of what happened
in Avengers infinity war where Thor
drove Stormbreaker through thanasis
chest but of course he is saved by
Captain America finally lifting mule
near this is something straight from the
comics that everybody has been waiting
for for a very long time and was teased
in Avengers age of Ultron where Captain
was able to slightly move mule near
Captain is even able to use lightning
the reason of this of course is the
enchantment on mule near that says
whoever possesses it will possess the
power of Thor
so with that power comes
but it ultimately isn't enough to defeat
Thanos and Thanos eventually ends up
breaking Captain America shield which is
directly from the Infinity Gauntlet
comic everybody is defeated and then it
is just Captain America the last one
standing against Thanos this is also
directly from the Infinity Gauntlet
comic captain being the last one against
Thanos not giving up it seems like all
hope is lost but then of course we hear
Sam say on your left this is a callback
to the Winter Soldier when Captain
America would pass Sam on the track
field and he would say on your left and
then we see Doctor Strange bring all of
the Fallen Heroes that are now back to
life into the battle this is also right
from the comics where Doctor Strange
brings everyone to Thanos to fight him
we finally get to hear Captain America
say Avengers Assemble and the fight
begins from here there are a ton of
references Easter eggs and callbacks
starting with one that many people
missed Howard the Duck it's so awesome
that they threw him in the scene once
the fight begins they realize they need
to get the Infinity Gauntlet back to the
past and the only option is ant man's
van we hear the wasp say we're on it cap
which is a reference to ant-man and the
wasp or she would make fun of ant-man
for saying cap Peter and Tony finally
reunite and we find out that people who
were dusted actually remember being
dusted and Peter finally gets his hug
from Tony unlike what happened in
spider-man homecoming the gauntlet then
makes its way across the battlefield
first Hawkeye has it and then Black
Panther takes it when Black Panther
takes it he says Clint give me the
gauntlet this is a reference to Civil
War and Civil War Hawkeye says my name
is Clint and black panther says I don't
care now it seems like he has some
respect for him this is also a direct
reference to the comics where Black
Panther wields the Infinity Gauntlet
himself then spider-man takes the
gauntlet and we finally get to see his
instant kill mode that was mentioned in
spider-man homecoming then Captain
Marvel comes in destroys Thanos his ship
and goes to Peter and gets the gauntlet
from him we then see all the female
heroes gather with Captain Marvel this
is a direct reference to the a force the
all-female superhero team and probably
foreshadowing and setting it up for the
future a team in the MCU we also seek
will interact with 2014 Gamora
Peter is shocked to see her alive but of
course it's not the same Gamora it's
2014 Gamora she kicks him in the nards
and then ran
eventually Thanos destroys the quantum
tunnel and ant-man's van and gets the
Infinity Gauntlet from Captain Marvel
right then Tony looks at Doctor Strange
and Doctor Strange puts up his finger
signalling one meaning the one scenario
in which they win and immediately Tony
knows what he has to do he goes against
Thanos and manages to get the Infinity
stones from the Infinity Gauntlet before
he snaps his fingers he says I am Iron
Man
the phrase that started it all and now
he's using it to end it all after he
uses the gauntlet he of course begins to
slowly die pepper comes to a side and
tells him that you can finally rest he
then dies and everybody starts to bawl
their eyes out in Tony's hologram
farewell message he says that if you
would have told me a few years ago were
not alone in the universe I wouldn't
have believed the extent this is a
reference to the very first post-credit
scene in the MCU where fury tells Tony
he's not alone and this is where the
very first Avengers initiative began so
it's amazing that the end is referencing
the beginning we see Tony's first arc
reactor that pepper made for him that
says proof that Tony Stark has a heart
at his funeral all of the heroes are
there including happy Hogan Hank Pym and
Harley keiner the little boy from Iron
Man 3 many people did not know who that
teenage boy was but it is in fact Harley
keiner quite possibly setting it up for
him in the future to become iron lad or
Iron Man and definitely a possibility
for a future Young Avengers after the
funeral Wanda and Clint reunite and he
tells her that he wishes he could tell
her that we won and once says she knows
they both do now some people think that
Wanda is referring to Natasha and Gamora
but I think she's referring to Natasha
and vision Thor joins the guardians of
the galaxy setting up guardians of the
galaxy vol 3 and creating the as
guardians of the galaxy which in fact
was a comic we then cut to a scene where
Captain America is going to go back in
time to return all of the Infinity
stones at the time where they took them
captain says to Bucky hey don't do
anything stupid until I get back and
Bucky says how can I you're taking all
the stupid with you this is the same
exact conversation that they had and
Captain America the First Avenger except
it was reversed
Bucky then says I'm going to miss you
because Bucky knows that captain is not
going to come back he's going to stay in
the past and that's exactly what happens
professor Hulk explains that he's only
going to be gone for five seconds in
their time but for
him it'll take as long as he needs of
course five seconds goes by and he
doesn't come back
instead old man Captain America is
waiting on a bench he explains that he
stayed back in time and the Risser
brothers have explained that he did in
fact create an alternate timeline but he
simply returned to this timeline at the
end to give Falcon the Captain America
shield so he can become the new Captain
America this is something that happens
in the comics in fact Bucky also becomes
Captain America at some point in time in
the comics as well which is why we see
Falcon look at Bucky and Bucky gives a
nod of approval saying that it's okay
you can be Captain America this is
something that will most likely see play
out in the new Bucky and Falcon TV
series on Disney Plus and of course we
find out that Steve finally got his
dance with Peggy Carter married her and
lived out his life happily and of course
after the credits we hear a clanking
noise this is a reference to the very
first Iron Man film where iron man makes
the very first Mach one Iron Man suit
that was the very first movie that
started the MCU and Avengers in game is
the movie that is wrapping up the story
arc for the first eleven years of the
MCU so the post credit scene brings it
full circle and that's it for my
complete breakdown of Avengers in game
and all of its Easter eggs I hope you
enjoyed it let me know what you think
about Avengers and game in the comments
down below if you're new to my channel
be sure to subscribe so you can stay up
to date on everything relating to
Avengers in game all things Marvel and
all things superhero as always thank you
all so much for watching
woof woof
congratulations to your desperation to
save the universe you killed half of its
population yeah you did it very nice and
dull it took you said it cost you
everything while crying like a baby now
you're it